thank you for joining us America with
glad you aren't here michael is with us
in Raleigh North Carolina hey Michael
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
thanks appreciate you taking the call
sure what's up so I went to Smart Money
back in May did a show in Durham and it
was a fantastic service it's really
informative and really entertaining
which I was surprised um I thought money
seminar wouldn't be as entertaining as
it was and all it really was like thank
you left the next day and um ain't got
my state-specific wheel and and went ah
found one your LPS and started a Roth
401k and I'm checking it out right now
and I basically says I've lost I'm a
negative five point one one percent on
my annualized since initial investment
and my year-to-date I'm also negative
five point one percent and is that
because I'm just I'm wondering why is
that because you know I've seen on the
news the stock market is going up and
and my 401k is actually gaining at about
seven percent on-year today which you
know I didn't did he pick the wrong
funds to put me in or do you know can
you explain to that well I think you
probably need to get on the phone with
them and find out exactly what you're in
and let them dissect your statement with
you okay right the thing is you need to
pick your funds they don't need to pick
them you know it's your job to look at
the funds and understand what you put
money into and so they're supposed to be
teaching you as you're buying so you
know why you picked a fund and based on
that you're comfortable with it
now I don't know what's happened there
it's possible that the fund is broken
even and that the the fee the five and
three-quarter fee has gotten you did you
if that's how you set it up deal and so
you've not recovered the feedback is
what it amounts to and that that would
be or not all of the fee a portion of it
it's what it sounds like and I honestly
have not looked at the stock might mean
I know the markets up a post Trump
election prior to that it was down and
and I don't know what it is your to date
right but you're comparing it to your
401k which is a fair comparison and if
your 401 k's up and i gosh I don't even
I hate to be so lame but I do not look
at them that closely to where I can even
tell you what the markets done for the
year
overall I have to stop and look that up
but that's something you could do you
could look and say okay what's the
standard and poor are done for the
standard for 500 done for the year and
you can you can google that when you get
off there with me right now and you'll
know and you'll go okay it's up 6% or
it's up 2% or whatever it is and then
you can call smart investor guy and go
okay dude wise mind down five walk me
through this because this doesn't feel
right okay it didn't feel right to me I
wanted to ask you before I called him ya
know I mean the thing is I'm not
positive what's happened in your
particular case
but but I am I'm with you find out and
take this as a learning opportunity to
go okay so that the next time the
question comes up you can answer it for
yourself you know right because you you
know you've you've done the but you did
one good thing automatically and that
was go back and compared to your 401k
compared to an S&P 500 on Google and
call him and walk through the statement
okay did we pick a pad bad fund here but
I don't ever want you investing in
something because I said to or because
someone else that don't you to
understand what you're putting money
into to where you have a comfort level
where when these questions come up you
don't second-guess the choice and you
know it sounds like though that there's
a reason to look at this definitely a
reason so I'll try to look that up I'm
now you got me curious as to what's
going on so markets up 9.41 from the
beginning of the year the S&P is and
he's down five say that's not good
that's not good that fund may be weak
it's possible you did get into a weak
fund then so they looked up the red
return Michael while we were talking in
the booth and so yeah if the market's up
almost ten for the year then and you're
down five for the year that's not
explainable by the fees unless you got
in late in the year let's see when was I
in Durham you know I don't know where
you are
did you start in January you know and so
that kind of stuff says what you could
compare to two but anyway dig into it
learn
and you either move funds if you
dissatisfied with a smart investor got
moved to a different one smart mr. Pro
that's fine but the big thing there is
to always know and learn and thank you
for calling me to do that because I
don't have the answer to your question
in your particular case but but I
commend you for scratching and digging
and learning which is what you should do
because we always you know you always
want to work with an investment
professional that is the heart of a
teacher meaning that you are learning
that's what you're looking for and
that's what the smart Wester pros
specialize in so they won't be offended
at all whoever your person is when you
call and you want to know more about
your stuff and you're not questioning
their ability you're questioning the
decision and how these numbers crunched
out and it's a good question hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
you